eine große aktuelle studie zeigt die
fleischproduktion ist ein riesen
klimakiller demnach sind die fünf
weltweit größten fleisch und molkerei
konzerne für mehr treibhausgas
emissionen verantwortlich als der
ölkonzern exxonmobil ein unfassbares
ergebnis was genau dahinter steckt und
was sie selbst tun könnte um den
globalen temperaturanstieg zu begrenzen
erfahrt ihr jetzt mal klicks von science
fiction herzlich willkommen dass kühe
beim verdauen klimaschädliches methangas
ausstoßen ist nichts neues auch nicht
dass bei der weiterverarbeitung und dem
transport von milch und fleisch co2
emissionen entstehen
doch dass diese branche so extrem zur
erderwärmung beiträgt dann hätte hätte
wohl kaum jemand gerechnet doch genau so
lautet das fazit der aktuellen studie
vom institut für ex-coach and trade
policy mpp in diesem bericht heißt das
konkret gemeinsam sind die fünf größten
fleischer molkerei konzerne bereits
heute für mehr treibhausgas emissionen
pro jahr verantwortlich als die
ölkonzerne exxonmobil shell oder bp
wer hätte gedacht dass die ja eigentlich
natürliche produktion von lebensmitteln
mit den großen ölkonzernen konkurrieren
kann dabei geht es hier um alle
emissionen der fleischproduktion
zusammengenommen also das ausgeschiedene
methan aber auch dass beim transport
produzierte co2 und für die zukunft ist
keine besserung in sicht im gegenteil
wenn man davon ausgeht dass die fleisch
und molkereibranche in den kommenden
jahren weiter wächst steht uns ein
kollaps bevor die macher der studie
die kritisieren die verantwortlichen
unternehmen hart da der großteil viel zu
niedrige werte in seinem co2 bilanz
angebe auf würden die emissionen
komplett in der lieferkette
ausgeklammert oder gar nicht darüber
informiert
dabei handelt es sich dabei um bis zu 90
prozent der gesamtemissionen
nachvollziehbare und vollständige
missions- berichte gab es nur von vier
konzernen
die studie nennt in einer liste die co2
verursache auch beim namen
der deutsche molkereikonzern dmk
befindet sich auf platz 21 auf platz 24
folgt der fleischkonzern tönnies den
zweifelhaften ersten platz belegt ein
konzern aus brasilien
gbs dahinter folgen drei us unternehmen
mehr als unverständlich also dass die
politik bis heute keine genauen
klimaschutzziele für die landwirtschaft
vorgibt dabei hatte die ernährungs und
landwirtschaftsorganisation der
vereinten nationen fao schon 2006
verdeutlicht welch große rolle die
fleisch- und milchproduktion bei der
globalen erderwärmung spielt zwar hatte
man dann beim klimagipfel in paris vor
drei jahren angemerkt dass auch der
nahrung sektor emissionen reduzieren
muss aber dabei ist es gefühlt auch
geblieben im krassen widerspruch dazu
stehen die ziele der entsprechenden
konzerne in den kommenden jahren ihr
geschäft auszubauen und zu wachsen so
beispielsweise die brasilianische firma
gs die davon ausgeht dass der
fleischkonsum pro kopf in den kommenden
zwölf jahren um 30 prozent steigen wird
das sagen die nämlich ihren investoren
dabei wäre genau der entgegengesetzten
trend wünschenswert und vor allem auch
notwendig um die globale erderwärmung
auf zwei oder sogar 1,5 grad celsius zu
begrenzen lavigne bis müssten die
deutschen dazu ihren fleischkonsum
halbieren in den kommenden zwölf jahren
auf 22 kilo singen pro kopf und jahr bis
2050 sogar auf 16 kilogramm pro person
und jahr
dazu heißt es in dem greenpeace bericht
damit auch die landwirtschaft einen
beitrag zum erreichen der pariser
klimaziele leistet und das artensterben
gestoppt wird müssen die deutschen bis
zum jahr 2050 ihren fleischkonsum und 50
prozent senken
pestizide müssen von den äckern verband
und die mineraldünger deutlich reduziert
werden in die pflicht genommen werden
müssen vor allem die
hauptverantwortlichen exportregion von
fleisch und milchprodukten
dazu zählen die usa kanada die eu
brasilien argentinien australien und
neuseeland denn hier herrscht eine
überproduktion vor und ein extrem hohe
pro kopf verbrauch obwohl hier nur 15
prozent der weltbevölkerung leben machen
diese region 43 prozent der weltweiten
emissionen der fleisch- und
milchproduktion aus die aktuelle studie
zeigt jedenfalls noch einmal die
dringlichkeit dass nicht nur der
energiesektor hinsichtlich der
klimabilanz überprüft werden muss
sondern auch die großen fleisch und
molkerei unternimmt die bisher
bestehenden regelungen sind freiwillig
und werden weder durch unabhängige
überwachungssysteme noch durch
sanktionen und
stützt und durchgesetzt ein eklatantes
problem für die zukunft von uns allen
schande genug dass die politik das
bislang verpasst hat aber ihr könnt
etwas tun und es ist ganz simpel es
einfach weniger fleisch wenn er kein
video dazu zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann hättet mich bei
whatsapp dann um geht dir die etwas
unzuverlässiger aber boxer auf youtube
und ihr verpasst kein video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
persönlich von jedem upload und zwar
noch vor allen anderen täglich und
garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und
am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal
klicks um social media abonnieren da
gibt es das neueste aus der social media
welt dafür
hier klicken aber nicht die glocke
vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür
auch draufklicken ja klimawandel
bestätigt skeptiker endgültig widerlegt
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran